du tout alors face à troyes auxerre
gagné à tout public un téléphone bon
anniversaire
thales a gagné 1500 euros j'adore le
faire ou sa salle elle adore je veux pas
qu'on m'appelle marie pelt alors j'ai dû
faire gagner 1000 stationner c'est
gentil je vais c'est ça qui m'a première
étude appelée hier ouais mais j'ai envie
de rappeler j'ai jamais je vais essayer
d'appeler mon anniversaire attend que je
retourne à sky
on va donner mille cinq cents euros je
vais poser des questions sur la carrière
de difool holà aux deux chroniques voilà
mauvaises réponses et l'appel se
retourne complètement sur nos
chroniqueurs et tout public gagne son
smartphone
on est en direct il est 20 heures 10 la
viande alors il ya tout à kiel comme ils
sont bien à toute l'équipe pas voilà je
lisais la star de l'équipe c'est mais
des livres bien sûr medellin le cherche
à me serrer la main sur les habitudes
lamari karim assure karim que j'adore ya
sam sam magnifique et aux magnifiques
j'aime énormément et lui lui qui croit
qu'il a la cote à quoi je donne ces sas
avec au bout de bras c'est un message
pour snc guillet ouais là yaté opéra
lisa morning il manque romano qui vous
auront ce mec est vite fait un
permanence à leur amour douala m
alors attention on va poser des
questions soudain il reste laveront
attention le chiffre 12
c'est quoi jean michel lemaire et sophie
cost pour le chiffre nous c'est l'âge
qui l'avait quand il a commencé la radio
au sénat qu'il a maintenant c'est le
nombre de kilos qu'il a pris sa première
année de libre antenne
alors pas de vol pour vous cyril et sauf
que je suis un pro des médias je connais
très bien la carrière de difool il a
bercé mon enfance
mélina en 78
la 202e elle a pas versé tendance en soi
[Applaudissements]
c'est que les 918 à tour voit son père
était médecin il a commencé la radio à
12 ans dans son garage à une de potes
c'est vrai ça c'est un spécialiste des
médias n'importe quoi mais 12 ans 6 et
12 ans y mettez tombe bien c'est pas du
tout j'étais pas mettre sa quand
apparaît doute c'est bien douze ans que
tu commences à radio sur sw cas oui une
radio rock punk reggae de saint-etienne
avait des preuves thématique des crêtes
et très fort j'aime bien je voudrais
bien jean michel mr bones
[Applaudissements]
beaucoup de fans dans le studio
le chiffre 3 c'est le nombre de fois où
des foules s'est fait virer d'une radio
ou c'est le nombre de semaines qu'a duré
sa première libre antenne avant d'être
interdite par le csa à ça peut être une
interdiction du csa éventuellement parce
que difool il était quand même très
subversif bon si effectivement au bout
de trois semaines il a pas eu quelques
problèmes il faut le caler à voir répond
claude réponse est la tienne bravo et
oui l'émission c'était le dif ou loire
oui exactement elle a duré que trois
semaines en semaines interdit pas le
sait ça mais oui mais comme saturn est
comme ça en fait on prenait les
auditeurs les auditeurs ont laissé à
l'antenne et on les laissait pendant une
demi-heure par les ensembles bas et donc
s'ils repartent en cacahuète donc c'est
parti les premières les premières libres
antennes on avait lancé ça on avait
lancé sa les paul couet attention
troisième question 1,5 c la note qu'il a
obtenu en maths au baccalauréat ou c'est
le taux d'alcoolémie auquel il a été
contrôlé après une émission bien arrosée
très bientôt dans les deux cas c'est
super ça lui alors mais moi je pense que
c'est quoi difool vous jouez avec nous
chez vous
à mon avis voit pas ça quand on fait la
libre antenne le soir il faut qu'on soit
sobre sobre et sa wii sabrer sa donc je
pense que c'est la note son baccalauréat
oui bien il s'empressa est idiot si
c'est bien la note qu'il a obtenu en
matériel
cinq romans et en sus un très beau deux
ennemis en physique
tout ça ça aussi c'est pas si bien fait
de venir
et oui et ça n'empêche pas les marchés
la carrière qu'il a fait calme-toi
calme-toi il ya comme une question cyril
alors attention km question le chiffre
90 et justement j'ai décidé de changer
les règles
[Applaudissements]
le tractopelle ce retour
juni nanard jour qui lisez ces ions le
site fraude 90 c'est son premier salaire
d'animateur radio offrant donc 1904 en
iso ou c'est l'année où il a décidé de
prendre le pseudo de des foules 90 ça
leur a jamais de citer jean at il cédé
au moins alors j'aurais dit les pieds on
n'écoute que je fais ça lui des médias
et le jean michel vernhes sofipost j'ai
le paquet d'idées non parce que
regardent 1990 ça peut pas être s'en
étonner c'est pas qui part gagné des
millions non plus de 1990 améliorée en
2000 son premier salaire non mais ce
qu'il était hyper jeunes alors aux
écrans son salaire non allez si l'on
prend son salaire allez j'en ai mis
difool falloir des noms en 90 étudiants
animateurs pour le week-end et la nuit
sur fun radio
oui et en fait tu t'appelles david
massard oui on dire annonce 8 ans et
david masses africaines skyrock n'a pas
été possible à tout et tu choisis le
pseudo de difool pourquoi des foules
il a fait une campagne d'affichage de la
radio il avait dessiné
il avait fait de bandes dessinées et
fallait se prendre choisir des bandes
dessinées alors jeune chantre 13 bars
des foules dont j'ai pris bien free
alors on a retrouvé les images de toits
sur fun radio
c'est pour le love in phone regardez
bien on voit aussi coût et avec des
cheveux on a des amis regardez à quoi
avec des cheveux et difool tu es
magnifique avec des chaussées mail de m
en plus le cm2 préféré difool et et qu
il aime de sexualité mais des foules ne
change pas ses habitudes
je sais pas il ya 4 millions d'auditeurs
qui viennent chaque semaine écouter
cette émission
sk 4 millions de fer verre entre 15 et
25 ans je suis pas sur quoi le csa
souhaitait aussi que l'émission
programmée aujourd'hui soit enregistrée
en sera diffusée en direct
[Applaudissements]
la tête de cauet séménou potter et
boigny cauet et difool toi tu as l'air
intelligent de ouf
c'est fou on dirait vraiment les mecs tu
vois ton moi s'il était toujours à tenir
il est très intelligent dévoué alors
malheureusement malheureusement s'est
perdu et maintenant je suis perdu oui
c'est j'imagine que c'est pas très sympa
tristia au dessus si c'est super je vous
rappelle j'ai fait une greffe de cheveux
il ya un mois ça risque rien ici ça
tombe tout public gagne le téléphone
c'est parti
[Applaudissements]